bootle cat podcast you already know man
go watch our full interview Deontay
Hitchcock in the building his new album
comes out May 10th his new single woes
out and this guy's a top tier MC so
let's turn this to this [__] man come on
some days I wish that I could live life
twice because Lord knows that I ain't
live life right I mean I'm trying but
[__] too good for me to live like
Christ so I grab a pen and all my sins
all right I'm saying if Jesus really
died for my sins the least I could do is
make it worth it right make it have
purpose right instead of walking around
and talking down now perfect like and
acting like my [__] don't stain man I
done been on the brink or losing my mind
like a hundred thousand sometimes think
I'd be good with rejection much as I
watch my car decline in the checkout
line holding up the whole damn stove me
and the cash you look like that Diddy
mean from the foe but know as far as the
flow I'm on the ceiling with mine I'm
gonna make it out of this sketchy play
some scribbling lines and I'm gonna do
it with the [__] that I started it
with May y'all be linking up with [__]
and don't make a red scent now every day
I wake up proud make the mistake of
letting this cake come between me and
folks who help me back up cause with my
good Fellas I split the narrow boy if
you're in straight you [__] if you
don't make sure your man straight not
young oh dogs nothing you ain't Lorenz
tape but how I'm supposed to feel good
shining when all my friends came what
big say mama any more problems I know
it's Lonely at the Top but it's that Mo
at the bottom now I planted my feet by a
tree outside your grass greener from the
outside them thoughts poison yeah but we
need a little carbon dioxide for us to
really even be outside but lately I've
been in the house with my [__]
career and my kid writing raps while he
nap I pray to God that he give me at
least like 30 minutes or something so I
could chill tell Miss Rachel that she
going triple platinum over here for real
I got a dog a baby and I ain't Rich that
mean most of my day be spent dealing
with other people's [__] so this year
when it comes to them Benjamins I ain't
playing with these [__] at all like
Ben Simmons down I got this Theory by
single fathers and mothers Brown how
they all really just God's walking among
us cause the hardest thing I ever had to
do was raise a child and they be doing
it by themselves and they do that [__]
with a smile [__] how and this ain't no
disrespect to posting with it with their
spouse inside the house y'all just
saying who I'm talking about trust I
wanna see more two pound households for
the children but them folks who do it
alone just build different then you got
some folks so deep asleep the down
leaving dream they say bro that's just
make believe if I ask them isn't
everything we call a tree a tree but
someone had to plant the seed to weed
out all the names of other things I had
a chance to be and they ain't no
different than we I mean so what you
saying God made us creative with
everything created you mean to tell me
that she gave us all imagination just to
sit us down in front of campuses already
painted brush and stroke create so my
conscience leave the Earth and flow high
above the daily [__] that make me feel
so [__] low I need bands we made you
go tell a friend that's why few just put
the drum on a stick like a percussion
note we numb it to sensitized [__]
tweeting videos of death I feel like I
witness live Mama frying fish in the
kitchen I'm in the kitchen fry high as
[__] ran cause the neighborhood
getting gentrified granny say repent
like it matter if [__] sit and pray
wanna talk to God she never really got
[__] to say manager be [__] and I
really wish I can quit today Mama laid
off though [__] it I guess I gotta stay
27 in my account and I feel like a high
amount at the time being but I know the
millions is on the way cause my mind see
him got a drug test all my little
brother don't mind peeing in this
[__] Trojan we gonna be straight in
the moment hey see how many just reacted
that on the ground cool if you heard
that already then you a fan but under
these conditions I had to say it again
[__] this is my big day I ain't leaving
this [__] a chance bro all my albums got
no skips I'm talking Bayless cause I
ain't trying to go back to shopping for
[__] at Payless some [__] left they
ain't see the vision I'd be like Sailors
them [__] drop some dead weight but I
don't think I weigh less tell them
producers send me your best beats cause
all these other rappers sucks in the
five [__] to me for real this year I'm
speaking whatever I want to seek don't
tweak when them Seas gets on they gonna
reap
wow
[Music]
three-sided guy
that was [__] raw appreciate it
appreciate that [__] man appreciate it
sit in there hey I know you just watched
the new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week